chauvinism where does the word come from
[Music]
the term chauvinism er is French and
dates back to the 1830s there was a man
named Nicholas Siobhan so the story goes
who was the most loyal soldier in
Napoleon's Grand Army it was said that
he was born in rush for around 1780 and
enlisted at the age of 18 he served with
such dedication that Napoleon himself
presented Chauvin with a military award
the saber of honour Chauvin was badly
wounded in the war but remained a
fanatical Bonapartist even after
Napoleon's exile in 1815 and the
restoration of the monarchy his loud and
fashionable obsession with the good old
days of Empire made him into an object
of mockery and his name was given to a
ridiculous character in a popular play
of 1831 the word crossed the channel and
began to be used in English around 1870
then chauvinism meant belligerent
patriotism just as it did in France
rather like the English word jingoism
by the 1930s its meaning had evolved and
referred to a fanatical devotion to any
cause and hostility towards outsiders it
began to be used in journalism and plays
particularly when the unequal position
of women in society was being discussed
but it was in the 1960s and 70s that the
use of the word chauvinism really took
off amongst feminists the term male
chauvinist pig became popular turning up
in films and magazines including playboy
use of the word chauvinist peaked in the
1980s
other terms like sexist and misogynist
have risen a noose more recently but it
is President Trump's slogan America
first that really harked back to the
original meaning of chauvinism one that
the apocryphal Nicholas Chauvin might
even recognize if he ever really existed
that is
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon